Hey Joey, Joey's, he
called me a couple times.
Should I answer the phone? If he calls
calling back. Awesome Cock sucker
made a watch that Derek too.
Darrin tells over there eating pop tarts.
You weighs 500 pounds.
He's talking about Mckenzie
turns ass last night again.
He's terrible about that job.
What do you take? What you think?
That's my,
what do you think happened?
You think she's just eating all the
fucking time? I don't know Joey.
I don't know what purse.
She missed weight by seven pounds.
She's fucking smoking though, right?
She's very attractive girl. Okay.
Joey's right now in the middle of
bomb hits. You can answer that phone.
I'll answer. Hmm? Really?
It's, yeah, I'm surprised
that's not where he's
calling me. Oh, there it is.
Calling you back where you been dog?
Yeah.
What does that speaker, I'm at times I
had to call your were on the podcast.
We're on. We're on Jre la fight
companion live. What's up?
What are you doing there?
I am watching Dick like I should just
don't want people to see time to watch
people kick each other in
the fucking head. Today
you're on the air. You on speaker
phone. Now let me come on, man.
Cops.
You're what?
What are you doing a show at cops.
Oh,
La Cobbs is this Friday in San Francis.
One day this week on the show to discuss.
You'll call me Korea as a fuck.
And uh,
what do you call that fucking extra
extra terrestrial fucking comic.
What?
Right.
Well, I'm over here smoking the weed.
Daddy smoked, you know what I'm saying?
But Netflix next week I'm probably
going to tell them new asshole.
They came out last night to see uncle
Joey. I was dropping fucking dog.
No jokes on him. His
Shit. I'm ready to go dog
therapy right now just
listening to dogs by pink Floyd
therapy.
Then I'm going to pop up fucking podcast
and I'm doing a few spots that I had to
let these mother fuckers know
who's running things. And I said
Phil against Wonderboy and my man against
the other guy. I watch it tonight.
I'm tape
Joey, what time? What time
are you tapings on June 4th
seven and 9:00 PM in Las Vegas.
And where at? Where are the,
where are they filming that
downtown? I think someplace they got,
it's a small place. Joe was made for us.
It's like a seats less than the original
room. Nice and tight. Really. It's like,
it's like Providence, Rhode Island. When
was the last time you went to providence?
Probably years ago. That comedy
connection. Fucking deadly.
It's deadly.
And so is this is the same
type of layout to 50 to 40?
Are there tickets available? Uh,
there's no tickets available. I mean,
there's something for you. You know
what I'm saying? Right. If you,
if you show up in the helicopter,
I can't deny it. Yeah.
Power Copter than what you'll know days.
You know what I'm saying?
You just walk in and take the fucking
mic and tell people what's time.
But it's beautiful. But that's
it. There's nothing available.
I can't wait for people to see that
special. Joey's going to be fucking nuts.
I can't really, I'm working hard. I've
never worked this hard in my life.
I didn't know the meaning of this.
And so I listen to you or the
tapings and the try and shit.
And now I'm just doing 28
minutes sexual all week,
28 28 28 Oo,
I got to get the big,
I got to get the beginning more jazzed
up because I got to make them watch.
So I got to go out there like a
fucking medial, you understand me?
I got to go out there and holds him
to like 14 minutes and let them,
I got the strategy.
I'm going to go out there and fucking
just go off for about 14 then we go to
watch different corners and then
they come on, I pick my shots.
I just picked my fucking
shots like when fucking, uh,
Eddie's guys fought that dude and he
fucking took the really good striker.
I gotta pick my shots in the second round
and then the third round go out there
and just fucking four point combinations
ending with leg kicks the ted down than
the, until you can't take it no
more. You know what I'm saying?
That's the strategy, right?
Then I'm breaking it down
to three rounds. Joe Rogan,
you did it. You did last night. The
Ice House said, I told, I told Rodney,
set them on fire man. Yeah, no, no, no.
I broke it down to three rounds
and I'm cutting not in an addict.
You know what I'm saying? I'm cutting.
I'm looking at it like an MMA fighter.
So I'm training for a fight.
So the first 11 minutes you guys fucking,
I got to jump on your criminal shit.
The whole fucking old school.
Old School veto the second round.
I'm just picking my shots like,
like a guy gets Edson
Barboza he picked his shots,
he picked them apart. He kicked him in
the side. He fucked up that sciatic nerve.
He kicks him in the body
and then the third round I come out like
fucking that black dude in the 70s that
sport when they gave him the bottle
filled with cocaine, milk Joe Rogan
fuckers don't know magic bottle.
Same One Dana brought out for
the fight against out though.
It's kind of Mcgregor.
That's the same one that gave fucking
don't tell me I know the
characteristics of that fucking milk.
Fuck you pick you're dealing with in
the third round we'd come out like
Brian was that trainer's
name? Uh, is that a manual?
Joe Rogan. We're watching
it right now. Jamie.
Just put it on Alexis, our guayle.
Alexis Aguayo. Aaron Pryor.
Panama Lewis gave him the bottle with
the original should it shouldn't know
Diego was sending up.
Yeah,
he gave me tell him some
coconut water though.
Looking back and then Aaron Pryor came
out just throwing bombs and fucked Alexis
Aguayo up. That was a great fight, man.
This is the way you gotta do
it, man. Old School boxing.
Aaron Pryor, the bottle.
It's fights up bottles.
I called the bottle that I said
get on the bottle that I mixed.
Did they capture that on video?
It has a bottle.
Give him the bottle that I met
with smoke coming out of it.
I wonder what the fuck was
in that thing. Cocaine. Damn.
He's doing work. Look it up. Where's
the box? I'll get the other one.
The one that I'm mixed. Look at it.
Okay. There's no, no, no, not that one.
Give me the other one.
Okay. How fucking beautiful.
It's that that's one bottle sniff and
shit. No, that they try to get more than,
that was the one he goes.
Give me that one. Yeah. Bang.
He got hurt before he fucked out.
Alexis Aguayo had a nasty right hand man.
He was watery, his shit long. So this
is not the main event, is it? Yeah.
This is the main event. Can
we are all right, let's go
right back to, to the fight,
Joey. We're about to watch
one the boyfriends until we
love you, man. Love you, man.
Love you, man. I will see you this week,
brothers. Thank you, man. See it. But.